a bit slow on the uptake are we well
that means I'm out of your league I
always let people get one blowing as a
tribute because I can't restrain my
punches well enough when I turn back and
so I usually end up killing them hello
and welcome to Hunter hunter 101 the
series that breaks down everyone and
everything in the Hunter hunter world
and today we are going to take the time
to examine the powerhouse nen master
biscuit Kruger better known as Biscay
Biscay is a seemingly cutesy young girl
who first appeared in the greed island
arc however this isn't exactly an
accurate representation of her because
believe it or not Biscay is actually a
wildly muscular 57 year old woman who is
capable of changing her appearance
through nen and interestingly enough
unlike most known abilities in the
series iski isn't actually sure how she
acquired this power however it does stem
from the idea that the art of nen is
essentially an expression of one's will
and desires and so for most of her life
what Biscay wanted was simply to not
look like herself Biscay absolutely
loads her natural appearance and so
after years and years of wishing for it
to change it slowly but surely did and
now she's capable of assuming a form
that she would say better reflects her
idea of femininity and of course as a
result Biscay can be prone to the odd
violent outburst when reminded of her
true form or true age which is a
terrifying idea because the cutesy
appearance is certainly not to be
underestimated in her true form Biscay
possesses immense superhuman strength
and she retains quite a lot of that in
her preferred form having been shown to
be capable of inflicting instantly
debilitating blows without even
resorting to the use of nen although on
the flip side it's actually incredibly
easy to get on biscuits good side as all
you have to do is engage in you know a
little bit of light aesthetic flattery
and all of a sudden one biscuit Krueger
becomes a very agreeable person to deal
with with that said when it comes to the
realm of martial arts Biscay is
incredibly Stern and serious
towards both opponents and even allies
she studied at the shingen Rio School of
kung fu' found it by Isaac nattara
and is an incredibly talented and
merciless combatant who has no qualms
whatsoever with killing should the
situation call for it and using her
skills combined with her temperament
Biscay is one of the rare individuals
who holds the rank of a double star
hunter in this world meaning that she
has fulfilled the first five articles of
the hunt bylaws as mentored a student
held an official position and has
produced a remarkable achievement in a
particular field now miss Keys case we
don't know what the Aichi
it is but she is a stone hunter which is
someone who focuses on searching out
precious gems or other assorted niceties
and in fact it would be these pursuits
that would lead Biscay to becoming a
player in the greed island game in order
to seek out a rare stone by the name of
blue planet which she via various means
of accessing classified information had
discovered could only be obtained in the
game after entering greed island Biscay
came across gone and kilowatt and after
being denied an opportunity to join
their group she immediately set her
sights on ruining their friendship
beyond repair showing a are well her
very vindictive side to Biscay there
however eventually Biscay becomes
incredibly impressed by the potential of
the boys and declares herself their
teacher now very notably gone and kilwa
when not biscuits for students and in
fact her former apprentice was a man by
the name of wing who was actually
responsible for initially teaching gon
and killua about nan and heaven Zarina
but as expected from the teacher of
their teacher Biscay possessed
significantly more advanced knowledge
and abilities in regards to nen and just
on that Biscay herself is a transmitter
however she has also demonstrated
proficiency in a mission enhancement and
manipulation the latter of which is
particularly impressive due to the fact
that manipulation is the hominin type
the transmute is to master in fact
whiskey's particular signature han-soo
rely on a combination of transmutation
emission and manipulation resulting in
the summoning of a nan masseuse whom
Biscay calls cookie-cookie then goes on
to perform what is called magical spa
services whereby she applies a nen
transmuted lotion that is designed to
relieve fatigue as well as restore
general vitality making biscuits
abilities very well suited for efficient
training purposes
in fact one such technique is known as
the piano massage which allows her
recipient to have the equivalent of
eight hours sleep within a mere 30
minutes as well as accelerating the
restoration of aura pretty damn amazing
really one of the more incredibly
underrated nen abilities I think in the
entire series and it would be this
mechanism whereby gon and killua were
able to receive the equivalent of a
year's training in a single month but
Biscay is also a master of the common
major and advanced principles of nen
with one of her crowning showcases being
the power to hold a nobility cult ko for
13 minutes straight and this is very
very impressive because coat is
essentially a combination of almost
every other principle but namely ten set
to grant a su and go all in one neat
little package so it is not a simple
thing to pull off let alone master to
the point where you could hold it for 30
minutes and while Biscay was teaching
such magnificent techniques to go on and
kill aura she became
more and more enamored by their
potential and decided to remain with
them on their quest to complete the
great island game assisting in the
battle to stop the Bombers or playing
dodgeball against Razer which was a much
much harder task than I think I've made
it sound but in the end the three of
them managed to clear the game and as
thanks gone selected blue planet as one
of his rewards and then presented it to
Biscay who proceeded to name it blue
chime after this trio go their separate
ways with gone and kill was seeking out
Khan's father Jing although they would
soon reunite when Biscay was contacted
by palm Siberia to train gone and kill
her once more in order to win their
arranged match against the duo of
knuckle and shoot and rather importantly
it would be during this one month
training period the Biscay enlightened
kilwa to the fact that he had an
artificial sense of fear installed into
him which would lead to a moment of
extreme growth for Killa well later on
in the chimera ant are however after
doing everything she could for the boys
Hiskey once again said her goodbyes as
they went on to face knuckle and
shooting combat and then later became
part of the Chimera ant extermination
team following the events of the Chimera
ant arc Biscay became one of the many
hunters who volunteered to guard gone in
hospital and at the same time by virtue
of being a well known double star hunter
Biscay also became a candidate to take
the role of the thirteenth chairman of
the hunter Association following death
of Isaac Natura proving very very
popular Biscay made it all the way
through to the fifth round however she
could not secure enough votes to move on
to the sixth thus ending her campaign
but most recently Biscay was approached
by Cora pika to accompany a vast array
of hunters as well as the royal family
of the cocoon Empire on a voyage to the
Dark Continent where she as with
everyone else aboard has become
embroiled in the kaqun succession war
Biscay was recommended for this position
by kilowatt who also gave kropog a fair
warning of how to deal with Biscay you
know in regards to complimenting her
beauty and as such Crocker was
immediately able to own bisque ease
trust by stating that he would never
have hired such a delicate flower
without killaz recommendation and it
really was that simple from that moment
on Biscay was willing to do whatever
Cora picker was planning and speaking of
as for her specific role Biscay applied
and was selected to be a bodyguard of
13th Prince Mario the second youngest of
the legitimate cockin royalty and one of
the most under-resourced competitors in
the contest during this time Biscay has
also become a close compatriot of Hanzo
who was also hired by Crocker to become
a bodyguard although he is charged 12th
mince Mama's heir was quickly murdered
and so Hanzo joined Biscay in protecting
Mari I'm instead rather
interestingly mama's a is thought to
have been killed by a clone type
nobility which would greatly
incriminating so if his power were to be
discovered and so when the topic of Nan
came up in my rooms quarters Biscay took
the initiative and revealed her own
ability thus protecting Hanzo Biscay
showing her true form also had another
unintended result as well in that ver
gay the captain of maryam's guards
immediately fell head over heels for
Biscay describing her as follows how can
someone so beautiful exist the beautiful
yet sinister line from the trapezius
muscle all the way to the deltoids and
her hamstring it's a quiet yet
tyrannical bulge and he probably went on
and on in his head like this and
needless to say from that moment on
Fergie became much more cooperative
shall we say in regards to Biscay and
even volunteered to be taught an end by
her despite the fact that he had
previously held the belief that such a
power was mere superstition
so more fun facts about Biscay Biscay
rather unapologetically I might add
holds a keen enjoyment for naked men as
demonstrated when she became very
excited at the sight of a less than
clothes Hisoka during the Great Island
dong in addition to this Biscay is also
a frequent reader of men's fashion
magazines in her spare time although I
guess the term reader gets applied
pretty liberally here I mean more
accurately Biscay can be described as a
gawky of men's fashion magazines
according to the hunter hunter manual
section contained within the YuYu
Hakusho
official character book Biscay is one of
the most who probably accomplished
individuals within the series having
scored an incredibly impressive array of
numbers within the areas of mind skill
body nan ingenuity and intelligence
making her accordingly statistics one of
the most well rounded characters in all
of hunter hunter speaking of you hawk
show though as with many characters in
Hunter hunter Biscay does bear strong
parallels to a figure in Takashi's
previous story in this case being gang
Chi who both served as mentor figures
capable of transforming into younger
incarnations of themselves and who are
both comically referred to using old
lady names by their students this Keys
name is more than likely inspired by the
idea of a biscuit doll which are really
creepy shining a life like dull things
that were incredibly popular during the
late 1800s and nowadays are only really
good for serving as nightmare fuel
despite being a master of at least four
different brands of nan whiskeys body
transformation technique does not have a
defined
category of use it does however fit the
criteria for a specialist ability which
generally arise directly from the wishes
of the user but if that were to be the
case then Biscay would be classified as
a specialist rather than transmute oh so
for now that will remain a bit of a
mystery and finally a truly useless fact
in the 1999 anime adaptation Kilowog
does not initially count Biscay as one
of the greed island candidates because
he mistakes her for a doll and is very
very startled when Biscay does actually
move but that pretty much does it for
Biscay if you enjoyed this video and the
content this channel produce in general
then please do consider donating to the
New World review patreon because the
support of all of your amazing people is
what continues to make this channel
possible and if patreon isn't quite your
style then please do leave this video a
like share or subscribe because it also
helps support this channel an incredible
amount and if you'd like to join the fun
at any time then please do head over to
my discord server where a wide array of
shenanigan rain takes place on a daily
basis and finally please do comment with
who what or where you'd like to see
featured on the next hunter hunter
101
do you think Jing is actually one of the
strongest character all right this is a
tough question one that I could probably
waffle on for for like an entire video
but Jing is a very tricky existence
because we still effectively know
absolutely nothing about him I mean
typical show no logic would dictate that
a character in his position would almost
certainly be one of these strongest
characters but at the same time I have a
problem with using the term strongest
especially in regards to hunter hunter
because it implies that the only thing
to consider in the equation is power and
I think it neglects aspects like
intelligence which I believe is Jing's
primary strength until proven otherwise
at least he probably does have some
crazy cool abilities but the thing that
makes him a top-tier figure in this
world is just how masterfully he is able
to apply himself if we're going on raw
strength I don't think I put Jing up
there as one of the strongest but as
soon as you throw any other factor into
the mix then yes he is more than likely
a world-class level of danger all on his
own
have you watched Gundam double oh yes
actually in fun fact double it was my
first proper Gundam series before that I
had a hard time getting into the Gundam
realm because they used to watch a bit
of wing and seed here and there when
they were on Cartoon Network but they
never really gripped me at that age but
later on in high school a good friend of
mine heavily pushed Gundam double-o in
my general direction and I was just like
alright I don't watch it I guess and I
loved it I think the first season is
near perfection but sadly I definitely
didn't enjoy the second season anywhere
near as much but in any case double-o
did convince me to give out the Gundam
series a chance as well and I'm really
glad that I did eventually take the
plunge into that insane universe face
reveal when the face reveal now I guess
I hope don't forget that my face isn't
actually on this channel because on my
other channel my face is actually the
profile picture well there come to think
of it I really should change that to the
ground line review logo whatever the
case is the face enjoy